hello sir hello what's your name thomas
okay and where are you from i'm from
durham
durham all right but you live here now
yes okay very good off you go with this
story thomas uh so i asked a girl out a
couple of weeks ago
and she said yes uh which was great
because she's quite hot and
like already
[Applause]
once and then we rescheduled for tonight
and uh she cancelled on me again so she
could come
i have here pants tonight i thought i'd
come down and see if she wanted to
rearrange for next week
wow what are you going to say thomas
you're very keen
because she has given you no indication
that she is
dear well i guess he didn't look the
good thing is he didn't make other plans
that's good yeah okay so so this is your
decision now
this is you this is you sending a
message
to him so jessica are we going to flip
thomas or we're going to let thomas walk
this is oh okay
please kylie please will you lever him
off the red chair
[Applause]
literally dumped
they never even went on a date and he
got dumped
oh oh he's going to be having nightmares
the rest of his life
what is lovely because acting is a kind
of transient thing you meet people then
you don't but one of the lovely things
that came out of these films
is uh your friendship with uh ian
mckellen
now yeah do you know had you but you
must have known ian mckellen before the
films
oh yes since i was uh a teenager he's
two years older than me
um he said something the other day
really
along with what he was just said one of
the nicest things ever he said
yeah patrick stewart and i i i really
feel that last i have a brother
oh that's adorable he might have said
father of course
kind of a theory about the way he speaks
the way ear mckellen speaks
well we did an animated movie together
as well as these you did
yeah it was called flushed away i really
i really love
my son often says why was there no
sequel to that and i said because i lost
a lot of money but
it was remember he played the toad ruta
rita
and i was always like he can get like
consonants where there's nothing like he
can make a one-syllable
word into 20. okay here's a test for you
here's a test for you if you shut your
eyes
yeah cut your eyes okay is this the real
voice of you mcallen
or is it somebody doing in mcallen okay
graham is there room for another mutant
on that sofa of yours
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
why i'm dressed as i am i i've just come
down from scotland and it took
longer to get from city airport to us
and it took to get from edinburgh
so i'm still in the clothes i was
wearing up there oh you're very welcome
did you recognize this yes i this is
magneto's coke
is it really yeah they gave it to me
it's in red remember
look at it now yes
no you're not working tonight i refuse i
refuse
you're very welcome you're very welcome
i've got more to tell you about my
clothes
please please i was at kakadi high
school
telling them to be nice to each other i
go around schools doing that
gordon ramsay no brown
ray prime minister yes uh he'd been at
that school
and they gave me their school tie and i
said well i'm going on the uh
graeme norton show and i'll wear the tie
so i had to wear it so they're right
that's for cook eddie
nice they also gave me these um
no these shoelaces but they're rainbow
they're rainbows
are they footballers and footballers who
uh approve of gay people coming out and
being honest about themselves
uh wear these to show their support so
here we are
you are a trained sort of ninja yeah
uh have i been in a novice all-star
martial arts championship
yes uh did i get my face punched in
yes because we've got is it called the
nunchucks
nunchucks yeah that's the official asian
name yeah so the
we've got some content now i ought to
say that oh you've got some
because in this country nunchucks
apparently are illegal
unless you have some sort of
qualification which rebel has
and also these ones aren't these ones
these ones aren't the really dangerous
ones these are just i don't know where
we got them from
a toy shop
so yeah so don't mess around with your
nunchucks okay
so you can do a little nunchuck display
sure okay
just want to go like this during the
stunt routine
to protect yourselves i would go over
here and i would move down a bit
all right okay so wait john not me
would really help us if we didn't hurt
anyone during this okay
well people in the front row maybe just
protect your money makers
okay if you wanted music for this yeah i
mean you need music to do numbers
[Applause]
proper yeah so if you're thinking of
mugging me on the street
maybe think again but they made a dead
daniel yes they did make a dead me i've
had dead meats made before but this was
the one that got put through the ringer
like a lot but paul dano wanted me on
his back most of the time he got
very strong i better be around and
they're dead daniel
much excitement because dead daniel's
here
he's right here here is
it's like it's weird because it's like
it's like he's it's like he's dead
it's like he's dead pop it don't put it
next to me no no no you no
will he sit up not really
so yeah um touch his head touch his hand
touch his hand
it's so creepy yeah that's that's weird
oh come on dude
he's he really is sort of falling apart
at this point but he's been sent down
rivers he got mauled by a bear
like this was all things we did to him
during filming and it's really good
though look at the
look at the look at the the eyebrows and
stuff
yeah i know it's just
it's strangely horrible i don't know i
don't know what's happening to it at the
end of the press tour so
if anybody you know wants it
[Applause]
maybe not actually giving you enthusiasm
you
[Laughter]
based on that reaction there's no
telling what type of uh
experience dead daniel could have yeah
so yeah should i leave him here or
should i put him back i'm leaving there
for a bit okay cool you tell me when you
want him gone i mean it's quite
disconcerting because he is sort of
staring at me
[Applause]
wow i'm like only only very slightly
paler than him though
it's like one shade it's beautiful
here i did my fresh prince wrap eight
million youtube hits was on that
i can see your face you like what has he
left well this time i brought my dj
jazzy jeff
[Applause]
everybody
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
and yeah is
hey hold up
one more little surprise just for you
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
is
i don't think you're finished yet jeff i
don't think they're finished ready
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
don't
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
that
thank you so much wow
all right how cool is that
[Applause]
just a little treat for you a little
treat for you a treat
[Applause]
[Music]